ukrainian soldiers challenged by
separatists in a war that's become a way
of life since russia's annexation of
crimea in 2014
but fears are growing of a much bigger
russian invasion
ukraine's foreign minister told sky news
that he's working with allies like the
uk on ways to make president vladimir
putin think twice
we together with partners we have to
make this price unbearable for putin
they can strike economically we will be
fighting on the ground
and i'm sorry to say that but there will
be
a lot of dead russian soldiers and
we hope that president putin does not
want that to happen
but these satellite images suggest he's
not yet been deterred
they show a buildup of russian forces on
ukraine's border and inside occupied
territory
britain's new defence chief pictured
here giving his first speech this week
is watching closely
in comments made off camera he said
it's deeply worrying the significance of
the worst scenarios in terms of a full
invasion of ukraine would be on a scale
not seen in europe since world war ii
that admiral sir tony radican has chosen
to be quoted publicly speaking in such
stark terms about what a war in ukraine
might look like is a sign of the concern
being felt by officials in the ministry
of defense and across other nato allies
seeking to dial down the danger
president biden had a video conference
call with president putin on tuesday
good to see you again
biden has warned of unprecedented
economic sanctions should russia act
he could also send more weapons to
ukraine but u.s troops aren't poised to
join the fight
the idea the united states is going to
unilaterally
use force to confront russia invading
ukraine is not on the in the cards right
now
in a show of strength russian troops
start their winter training
their president denies wanting to invade
ukraine saying he just wants a guarantee
the country won't join nato
but that's an impossible demand as long
as ukraine remains a sovereign state
debrahim sky news